economía en france 24 conmigo en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela
buena noche bienvenida murió el
considerado mayor estafador de la
historia a la red el buenas noches se
llamaba o se llamaba bernard madoff y
tenía 82 años también llevo una vida de
película de un barrio obrero de nueva
york llegó a lo más alto de wall street
y terminó como uno de los más odiados
del mundo de las finanzas al ex
presidente de nasdaq multitudes de
personas le confiaron su dinero el
esquema que operó por décadas y que se
conoce como ponce y funcionaba de la
siguiente manera raúl a los primeros
inversionistas les entregaba altas
rentabilidades que pagaba con los que
traían los siguientes y así
sucesivamente después de captar unos 18
mil millones de dólares en la crisis de
2008 todos quisieron sacar su dinero al
mismo tiempo en ese momento tuvo que
admitir que su gigantesco negocio no era
más que una estafa comenzó a pagar una
condena de 150 años de prisión los
esquemas piramidales raúl también ha
sido muy usados en américa latina y
miles de personas han salido estafa
por la misma época de made off en
colombia estalló una pirámide conocida
como dmg que captó más de 2 mil millones
de dólares es increíble que se conoce en
estos casos y todavía la todavía existe
la estafa así es daniela la ocde
presentó un informe con recomendaciones
a cada país latinoamericano bueno esta
organización internacional que reúne a
las naciones más desarrolladas del mundo
hizo propuestas a diversos países para
que puedan recuperarse de la crisis
comenzamos en colombia donde ve poco
probable que el gobierno pueda sacar
adelante su tercer proyecto de reforma
tributaria con la que pretende aumentar
impuestos y recaudar cerca de 7 mil
millones de dólares esto debido a la
proximidad de las elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas de 2022 en
cambio en chile si cree que es momento
de hacerlo porque dice que la
redistribución del impuesto de renta es
muy débil y que debe mejorar
ahora vamos a argentina donde la oecd
criticó su baja productividad considera
que en primer orden de la agenda debe
estar un mejoramiento de las condiciones
para que las empresas prosperen compitan
y crean empleos de calidad para que se
cierre la brecha
social y terminamos en méxico donde el
club de países ricos surgió implementar
programas para la inclusión laboral de
mujeres pueden señala que apenas un 45
por ciento de aquellas con edades de
entre 15 y 64 años está en el mercado
laboral formal así es anger y luego una
tragedia nueva zelanda prohibió las
exportaciones de vacas vidas por vía
marítima si raúl lo hará a partir del
2023 debido a preocupaciones por el
bienestar de los animales este país
suspendió temporalmente esas
exportaciones el año pasado después de
que un barco que transportaba 5 mil 800
cabezas de ganado con destino a china se
hundiera en un clima tormentoso cerca de
japón matando a más de 40 miembros de la
tripulación y a todos los animales
escuchamos que dice el gobierno nos
llevan más nueva zelanda debe mantenerse
a la vanguardia en un mundo donde el
bienestar animal está bajo un escrutinio
cada vez mayor si realmente queremos ser
los más productores éticos de alimentos
en última instancia no podemos
garantizar el bienestar de sus animales
en el mar y eso es un riesgo inaceptable
para nuestra reputación
semana de resultados de la gran banca en
wall street y raúl en el primer
trimestre de este año las ganancias de
la gran banca estadounidense crecieron
exponencialmente tras un año de crisis
en el que sin embargo no mostraron
pérdidas y elvi morgan la entidad más
grande del país cuadruplicó sus
utilidades hasta 14 mil 300 millones de
dólares goldman sachs que es la entidad
más expuesta a wall street' las
quintuplicó y wells fargo las six
duplicó hasta 4 mil 700 millones pero
esto son apenas tres de los más grandes
raúl y este jueves se esperan los
resultados del bank of america y de
citigroup y el viernes salen los de
morgan stanley y que por supuesto les
vamos a dar a conocer aquí en economía
por su plan ye la de cifra el día bueno
la cifra del día son los 85 mil millones
de dólares es la capitalización bursátil
que alcanzó con veis la principal
plataforma de negociación de cripto
monedas en su salida a wall street
su acción cotiza desde hoy en el mercado
nasdaq de las tecnológicas así de
janeiro como siempre muchísimas gracias
por todas
información económica como siempre nos
quedamos con esta cifra del día a
ustedes también gracias continúa con
nosotros muy buena noche
[Música]